so when we arrived in Congo we were
asked to work with with artisans to help
them mostly to export as we got to know
the artisans we realized that a lot of
the poverty that they were facing
although it had been caused in the past
by a lot of you know political
instability and war and all these things
it had become a way of thinking like a
prison for their mind where it became
very difficult for them to see other
possibilities outside of what they've
known and outside of what they have
lived and so we saw that the first step
to helping them move forward in their
lives wasn't to teach them skills
teaching business skills or teach them
how to do accounting or design or all
those things but it was really to help
them break those bonds that were in
their thinking and so to do that we
created a program that became what's
called leap Life evaluation and
adjustment program leap generally
focuses largely on producer groups and
produce individuals so you'll find
artisans who have their own businesses
or who Cobb or Locke brothers or
Fairtrade groups for examples like
mumble lulu that are working with
workshops and the people who've been
marginalized lib training came such an
opportune time when we actually needed
training that was going to cause a
paradigm shifts in the minds of the
workers and in the minds of the managers
when we did the evaluation at the end of
the year we saw what it did the workers
have also improved they are thinking of
what else can I do
outside bobaloo
in Masai culture the Masai women are not
allowed to own things they don't own
land they don't own cattle and so we
were sitting with a group of ladies now
my Anna who is like an association of
women and we're sitting in their office
and doing the training with them and as
Mike was trying to explore their world
they said no no we can't own things you
know and they felt so limited in that so
Mike just you know calmly asked them
he said well where are we right now and
he said well this is not my Anna's
office this is not Manas land they said
well who is now my Anna and then you saw
this spark in their eyes when they
realized we are now my Anna and this is
our land and from that it created a
change in their thinking all of a sudden
all these possibilities open in front of
them and then now my Anna began to look
as a group at how they can now buy land
together buy cattle together so that
despite the political difficulties they
have they'll be able to own landing on
cattle so it's one in a small example of
how leap can change the way people think
and give them a new vision for what is
possible for them it was like a wake-up
you know there are so many things that
we know but we also need to be reminded
sometimes and when we went to their to
the training it was a three-day training
and we learned a lot of things the key
to the success of leap is to find
someone to find a trainer that has that
spark Kenya we met with Mike Mucha WA
who himself is an artisan he's worked in
the paper he's worked with furniture
he's done several things he's also very
very intelligent and his intelligence is
grounded so he's able to interact with
the poorest of the poor with it with
people who are illiterate with people
who have had no education in Africa with
so much pressure so much financial
pressure so much stress under the
collapse of the extended family system
and with diseases like aids coming in a
lot of people have forgotten the ways
when they really used to enjoy what this
continent was like and are drifting
through life and once in a while when
you you have a program like lift that
gets them to stop and
begin to dream reflect yeah and begin to
break some of that and that the
limitations and challenge some of the
ideas they have about ourselves then
they begin to grow again Academy could
have a way or say may I leave what you
thing is before he used to drink but
after I go to the training although he
had been preached by very many people
that made him to stop drinking without
any pasta coming to preach to him and
that has really changed his life because
he's able to plan in the morning what is
able to do British is a mine owner in
the kisi area he's very visible in the
community but he was an alcoholic every
day you would see him you know
completely drunk and it was sad because
he had this source of revenue but he was
never able to make to turn that revenue
into a different life for himself and
for his family through the leap
trainings he decided to stop drinking
and he really did I all barely believed
it and people around that barely
believed it they said no no it's not
true
but then we saw this change you know
talking someone seeing that clarity of
thought and now managing his mind more
responsibly and and seeing that he has
vision for the future and vision for his
children and vision for his family I
mean it's it's something that is so
exciting it's difficult to to describe
leap technically is about getting people
to fulfill their dreams because we live
in a continent Africa that is so dynamic
and has so many resources it is so much
poverty around and you see so many
opportunities passed people by leap is
actually getting people to discover
themselves again to learn to dream get
the dreams that they had forgotten when
do i yang when were 810 years old and
believe that they can be whatever they
want to be in poverty often people see
themselves as being passive as being
completely
you know subject to their environment
and if you can just help someone to see
that no they are active participants in
their lives and they are active agents
in their environment that they have the
power to change things around them then
you have the beginning of something and
slowly now they start to see the the
potential for what they can do to make
their lives better
you
you